justice sheffield taking his opening
warm-up tosses to austin nola he has not
won a game in the big leagues he's got a
550 era so sheffield will go to work on
simeon swung on ground ball one hopper
to third up with the ball kyle seeger
toss across in time and there's one away
here's center fielder ramon loriano
really one of the few guys hitting in
this lineup fish to ramone is a live
drive to left center for a base hit
solid single to left by lariato and
that'll bring up canna sheffield out of
the stretch lauriano running but they
got it picked off the throw goes to
first white throws to second but
lauriano beats the throw ramone was
picked off and reacting quickly lauriano
took off for second base and beat the
throw so ramon in scoring position swing
and a miss by canon for strike three and
sheffield has his first strike out of
the ball game and here is third baseman
matt chapman swung on fly ball at the
end of the bat straight away center
field kyle lewis is there puts it away
for out number three underway here at
t-mobile park we go to the bottom of the
first athletics nothing and the mariners
coming up on the mount for oakland is
big right-hander frankie montas
with a 3.00 era two starts off speed
swung on and missed crawford case
and that's how the bottom of the first
begins so here's shed long who's batting
at 250 with a home run and four runs
spat it in swinging a chopper over the
mound charging the second baseman pinder
one hands it throws the first not in
time an infield base hit for shed long
and that'll bring up center fielder
kyle lewis fastball 96 is swung on her
missed and lewis
strikes out good morning good afternoon
good night and the second strikeout for
montas and that'll bring up kyle seeger
swing ground ball near the bag at third
gets on by for a base hit browning
second heading for third is long up of
the ball is canon the throw will go into
second base so kyle seeger's slow roller
the other way has a base hit beating the
shift now the mariners have runners on
it first and third with two outs way to
go kyle now the mariners are threatening
with austin nola coming up a swung out
of miss and a fast ball away so montage
strikes out three and it keeps the
mariners off the board just this
sheffield has given up just one hit so
far good stuff so far from justice
sheffield stephen pascotti beginning the
frame swaying in a miss and a breaking
ball gaddy good start to the third
inning for sheffield with his second
strikeout right down the pipe called
strike three have a seat
that's three strikeouts for justice
sheffield breaking ball down and antag
applied by nola great job by sheffield
strikes out the side crawford moves to
scoring position at second base so
here's seeger and he's been the best for
a mariners team that's been very good
with runners in scoring position on line
drive base hit into the right field
corner easing around third and scoring
is crawford digging for two is sieger
and he'll get there standing up and rbi
double the meridians have a one-nothing
lead and he is having the bases loaded
right now lorianno is the last guy in
the world we want to pitch to as the
ezra still trying to get on the board
swung on a ground ball into right field
for a basic that will score davis
biscotti's around third he will score
and the a's have taken a two to one lead
and the better will be left fielder mark
cannon
and very high gets away from nola back
to the screen murphy has scored laureano
goes to third and the take a three to
one lead on a wild pitch
and then cannon shoots on the right
field and that's a base here lorianna
will trot home and now it's four to one
olson draws a walk and the a's have the
bases loaded one more time and here is
chad pinder for the second time here in
the top of the fifth inning the a's have
now batted around breaky ball is laced
into center for a base hit that will
score two runs and the a's take a six to
one lead and these were the huge their
biggest inning of the young season
here's chris davis tapped our third
attempt played charging seeger bare hand
bobble no play olson scores from the
third
seven to one a's the inning continues
for the athletics brings up right
fielder stephen cuscotti
that one's hit hard and that's fair down
the third baseline pender's gonna score
and it's an eight run
chris an rbi single in that uprising
when 14 batted and eight scored all with
two outs
fly ball to left back on it goes
marmaleo's at the track at the wall and
it is gone
chris davis welcome to 20 20.
as he cranks one out as the a's now take
a 9-1 lead and that's going to load the
bases and that's going to give marcana a
chance to put this game away basketball
that's outside ball four he walks in a
run and the a's now lead a 10-1
murphy will waltz home and mark gets his
second rbi of the night montas tonight
is struck at eight walked four only run
he's giving up a third inning rbi double
by kyle
come back fastball
hits the edge and smith not happy he is
gone and looking that's nine strikeouts
for frankie bounced on the left side for
the shortstop simeon gloves steps throws
one two three
seven in a row retired by mo toss seven
strong tonight now the athletics have
runners on it first and second and
that'll bring up matt olsen olsen it's a
drive to left center it's lost in the
lights by marmalaos and machine will
come around and he's going to score they
now lead by a score of 11 to 1. lou
trevino takes over mariners are down to
their final out here in the bottom half
of the ninth inning and that'll do it so
lou trevino
gets the final three outs and the a's
take three out of four